we will
be making the existing
covid pass
compulsory for everyone
attending high risk venues
and the high risk venues that will be
covered by
the need to display a covet pass
will be night clubs and similar venues
indoor
non-seated events
for more than 50 people
that would include for example
conventions and concerts
it will cover outdoor non-seated events
for more than 4 000 people
and for any setting or event with more
than 10 000 people such as a rugby or a
football match
in future
demonstrating that you have a covered
pass
will become a necessary condition of
admission
now the covid pass confirms your
vaccination status or that you have had
a negative lateral flow test within the
previous 48 hours and in that way the
covid pass is different to vaccine
certification in a number of important
ways
it allows people to demonstrate their
covert status in other ways than just
through vaccination because it also
shows lateral flow test results
it is freely and widely available now
and is already being used
and venues and events
can easily read the covet pass
with technology that already exists and
is available to them free of charge
the covid pass system has been used by
many festivals and concerts over the
summer
including the green man festival here in
wales
and when elbow and the manics play at
the motor point in cardiff this weekend
the audience will already know
that they have been asked to show a
covid pass in order to gain entry
now we will make the use of the covid
pass compulsory
in the high risk venues that i've set
out
from the 11th of october
so we will use the next three weeks
to work with venues
and the events sector to prepare
for its introduction
to give them the time they need
to make it a success
and the reason that we are doing it
is to avoid having to take
any more intrusive measures
to deal with coronavirus
we want to do everything we can now
to keep wales open
and to keep whales
safe
these are examples
of the measures that sage calls low-cost
interventions
interventions and if we take them now
we hope will be enough
to prevent the need for tougher
restrictions later on
to make this work
to keep well safe
to keep wales open
we need everyone's help to bring
coronavirus under control
time and again
over the last 18 months we have
demonstrated that here in wales we can
do it together
and we can do it again
now